hi I'm Scott hunter and I'm here today
to talk about dotnet core 3 which you
can now use with the Visual Studio 2019
RTM we consider dotnet to be your
platform for building any type of
application whether that's desktop or
web we've added cloud mobile gaming IOT
and AI today I'm here to talk about
dotnet core 3 we have a preview
available now that runs on Visual Studio
2019 donek core 3 adds the ability to
build winform
WPF applications on dotnet core it gives
the desktop developer flexible
deployment side-by-side single-leg z4
web we have a whole bunch of new
technologies around building client
applications using razor components
using G RPC and much more we have
significant performance improvements
dotnet core has always been fast or
making it faster and we have new c-sharp
language features to make you more
productive and have less errors in your
code also dotnet core has always been
our open source platform and so as we
bring the desktop platforms WinForms and
WPF to.net core we've also made them
open source all the code is on github
for you to check out and contribute back
to us
let's talk about the journey from core
22.9 core 3 without a core 1 & 2 we
primarily had web and cloud application
types in dotnet core we're vastly
expanding the applications you can build
with dotnet core 3 now you'll be able to
build desktop applications with WinForms
and WPF IOT application is running on
raspberry PI's and small devices and
with ml net full support for machine
learning and AI all on dotnet core 3 our
big themes with core 3 are we want to
build great desktop applications so
we've got winforms WPF we brought entity
framework 6 all the things make it easy
to port your desktop application to
dotnet core we live in a world of ML and
AI we have a great library called ml net
that will ship as part of that in core 3
as well and then you know the web is the
web we want to make sure that we're the
best platform for building web so we
have a bunch of new features in the web
space so let's start drilling into a few
of these the first is desktop first off
we want to make sure that as you build
these desktop applications you can use
all of our frameworks and so we have a
new feature called Samwell Islands you
can take all of the controls in UWP
these are the touch enabled controls and
you can now host them directly in your
win for more WPF application imagine if
you want to sign with your finger in an
expense report application maybe you
want to use the newer browser or the
newer media player in your win form WPF
application you can now drag those in
and use those directly in those
applications and as monitors get bigger
with 4k and 8k we want to add a better
support for high DPI we want these
desktop applications to be able to
access all the windows 10 api's take
advantage of the latest features the
Windows operating system and all these
desktop features are also available in
dotnet framework 4.8 as well why core
why do you want to move your desktop
application to core there's a variety of
reasons that a core is our modern dotnet
it's the fastest version fastest moving
version of.net with all the latest
features so you get a bunch of cool
enhancements you get side by side you
can you're a developer can build a
winform application with dotnet core
using the latest version of.net core and
not worry about having your IT team
install a new version of.net framework
you can install that dotnet core either
machine wide or as part of your
application and even better what if you
don't install it at all check a box we
give you a single eggsy copy the exit of
the machines and they'll run with no
dotnet core installed at all so you can
use the latest versions the latest
features in your application without
installing anything on the host OS the
runtime and api's because dotnet cora's
side by side we've been able to actually
take some of the api's and enhance them
and make them faster without worrying
about breaking the backwards
compatibility of the applications and so
by using moving to dotnet core you get
our latest PCL with the latest features
performance because we've actually
modified some of these api's they're
just faster we see typically about a 30%
improvement when you move an app from
dotnet framework to about net core so
those are all the great reasons to move
your desktop application to core the
next thing as I said dotnet core has the
latest versions of all of the
technologies c-sharp ate one of the
biggest features feature-packed versions
of C sure up in a while brings a variety
of cool features I'm going to show a few
of them here quickly ranges you can see
under my getcustomer async i pass in
something and i basically can give it a
range instead of giving it the full
array i can say take this subset of that
array and pass that into that method
nullable reference types this is one of
my favorite features we all have
applications that we get null exceptions
in because we didn't do the right null
checks by enabling this in c-sharp 8 it
will actually force you to put the
question mark next to your customer
there because it could be null and it
could not be no you can see later down
there if name not equal null it the
compiler will actually enforce you to do
the right null checks for it we
introduced async/await
years and years ago and when it we did
it could return a single type now with
c-sharp 8 async can return a collection
an ienumerable of types so for the first
time ever you can return more than one
value from from an async method
so that's async streams we got switch
expressions recursive patterns and a lot
more as part of c-sharp 8 but there's a
lot of productivity
there the next thing is dotnet standard
dotnet standard is the contract that all
dot Nets must implement that makes it
easy to share api's across all the nets
with dotnet core 3 we're introducing
dotnet standard 2.1 and what you see
here is it's basically taking many of
those new features the index and range
the IAC cur numerable span of T which we
had in the previous version of net core
and making them available as part of the
standard we're adding these to the VCL
types and dotnet standard to point want
to be available across the xamarin
platform and the dotnet core platform it
will not be supported on that net
framework and we don't expect you to
move the donut standard 2.1 right away
maybe a year or so after that net core 3
is out and we have lots of developers on
dotnet core 3 will be the time but you
can see we're continuing to take the
standard and improve it
next thing asp.net dotnet core cannot
just be all about desktop that core 3
can't be all about desktop it needs to
have web as well so we have some amazing
improvements in asp.net we have G RPC
today we have asp net web api for
building restful api is using JSON but a
lot of our customers enjoy having
contracts which tightly define the types
that can be passed via an API and
because these contracts can also be
binary you get high performance so this
is giving you high performance RPC
contract based API is in dotnet core the
cool thing about G RPC is because it's a
standard implementation it works across
a variety of languages so it's supported
on Java node and many other other
platforms this means if you build a G
RPC endpoint in your deck or application
you can call it from a variety of
languages at the same time you can
actually call a GRC endpoint from net if
it's written in Java or something else
as well so it gives you full inter
interoperability between all these
platforms worker service asp net has
always been kind of associated with UI
whether it was web forms or NBC or razor
pages we've had web api but we really
haven't had a great point a great
starting point for building
micro-service e style applications and
so we're adding a worker service
template this template is for
building something they might run for a
long time in the background or might
listen for a message coming in from
something like a sure service bus we got
a great template for building these
types of applications that still give
you all the great features of dotnet
core dependency injection logging and
our high performance web server on the
backend the next thing is as you're
building these API is these Web API is
we know that one of the hardest parts is
securing these things and so we're gonna
make it very easy to partner with the
open source identity server project and
use that technology to secure your API s
we also have a really cool feature in a
net core three called razor components
you might have heard of this as blazer
in some of the talks we've done before
what this lets you do is build client UI
in c-sharp you no longer have to
actually depend on a library like
angularjs reactor view you can instead
take advantage of all the capabilities
of c-sharp for example you can have a
c-sharp object on the server and you can
pass it to the client now you get that
strong type all the way across both of
these things you might ask how we do
this we can run this on the server side
and have a JavaScript library on the
client that actually does the Interop or
even better we have something called web
assembly and this is a mechanism where
you can compile dotnet into pretty much
native il so when it runs in the browser
it runs it full native speed in the
browser
it requires no plugins all the browser's
support this the mobile browsers and the
desktop browsers and even better this
web assembly runs in the sandbox of the
browser so this is not like ActiveX or
flash or any of the plug-in technologies
it's safe stays within the context the
browser gives you that native
performance this is going to give you
the ability to build awesome spa
applications just using c-sharp so
you've seen a lot of the exciting new
things in net core 3 dotnet core 3 will
not ship as part of Visual Studio 2019
it'll ship later this year at the
Microsoft build conference in May will
actually announce the RTM date but
because you're running Visual Studio
2019 you can try the preview today
without hurting any of your existing
applications so please grab the preview
try it and send us feedback
[Music]